Freunde willkommen aus Hamburg Altona
ich stehe hier vor der Bullerei vor dem
Restaurant von Tim Mälzer es ist 12 Uhr
und ich habe Bock auf dem verspätetes
Brunch ich gönne mir jetzt ordentlich
was rein wir gucken uns den Laden an ich
bin sehr gespannt wie er sein wird denn
Tim Mälzer ist ein großer Name let's go
[Musik]
erster Eindruck wirklich sehr sehr nice
hier ich beschäftige mich ja extra im
Vorfeld nicht großartig mit dem
Restaurant weil ich will so die
Eindrücke auf mich wirken lassen und
hier fühlt man sich wirklich direkt wohl
also wir wollen sehr freundlich begrüßt
alternative Einrichtung also es ist kein
Restaurant von der Stange das setzt auf
jeden Fall schon mal so einen guten
Grundton natürlich wird das Essen heute
entscheiden ich fühle mich auf jeden
Fall sehr wohl wir haben uns ein
bisschen separat abgesetzt es gibt
diesen Vorderraum das ist gerade alle
anderen ganz entspannt reden vielen Dank
schon mal gucken wir mal und dann
bestellen wir Kleinigkeit schauen wir
also einmal auf die Karte also erstmal
eine wilde Auswahl keine genaue Küche
identifizieren was nicht irgendwie nur
italienisch nur asiatisch irgendwas aber
es ist eine geile Auswahl also fast
alles davon liebe ich das ist sehr cool
also ich persönlich mag die Auswahl
jetzt muss ich mich nur entscheiden weil
das ist jetzt die Schwierigkeit ich habe
ja eine große Liebe und schon viele gute
Burger gegessen und auch keine
schlechten gemacht so ich würde sagen
den bestellen wir einmal double Smash
Burger die Rahmen mit drin auf jeden
Fall und eine dritte Speise hatte ich
irgendwas besonderes angesprochen kannst
du doch was Lukas und Randy so
auseinander genommen haben ja okay dann
nehmen wir die drei Sachen Rest lassen
wir uns einpacken die Karte ist geil das
natürlich nur die Mittagskarte von 12
bis 16 Uhr also abends gibt's hier ein
ganz anderes Menü ich glaube dann wird
es wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen
komplexer gehobener wie auch immer kann
man wahrscheinlich auch länger Essen ich
weiß gar nicht genau aber das ist
erstmal eine gute Auswahl die bestellen
jetzt eine Sache muss man sagen die sind
hier auf jeden Fall sehr selbstbewusst
die lassen uns überall Film alles easy
so keine Tabus wenn man reinkommt hat
man einen kleinen Raum da findet glaube
ich meistens so die die Mittagszeit
statt wir haben uns jetzt ein bisschen
separat gesetzt sind im Hauptraum haben
sie selbst genannt und der ist wirklich
schön offen schön groß finde ich aber
auch immer mutig ne weil so ein Raum
muss ja auch voll sein damit man sich
wohlfühlt wobei ich finde ich finde es
jetzt ganz chillig eigentlich so super
fahren jetzt zum Beispiel dieser kleine
Aufsteller ein bisschen Gesicht wollte
besser fahren
natürlich auch noch mal viel
Aussagekraft haben
[Musik]
super danke schön okay machen wir das
ganze der Reihe nach zuerst probieren
wir mal das Katze Sando einfach mit
Pommes Pommes einfach muss ich sagen
nehmen wir einmal japanisch also das
kannst du sano am amerikanischen Smash
Burger Rahmen vielleicht auch japanisch
also ein bisschen quer durch die Karte
bestellt das sind aber wirklich in
meinen Augen Grund verschiedene Gerichte
wenn die wirklich alles gut machen in
diesem Restaurant dann ist das schon
absolut win und absoluter Mehrwert weil
ich kenne kein Restaurant in dem man
Rahmen und einen guten Burger essen kann
bisher noch nicht vielleicht heute lass
uns probieren
boah geil ich habe ein guter Vergleich
den wir heute ziehen können nicht von
der Küche aber ist der zu Steffen
Henssler Heu weil das war auch so im
Prinzip so Snack food würde ich jetzt
mal sagen so Komfort food aber halt in
einer besseren Ausführung auch hier
bewegen uns der Preis sich so zwischen
15 und 20 € pro Gericht kann ich mehr
als Mann in einem Imbiss quasi bezahlen
würde aber trotzdem noch einen normalen
Rahmen und das ist wirklich sehr sehr
krass also das kannst du richtig schön
gut fettig diese Katze Soße scheppert
richtig rein dieses Toastbrot macht
eigentlich genau alles richtig so ich
glaube das ist wirklich nicht mehr so
Roboter angetoastet sondern im Toaster
schmeckt besser als das aussieht noch
also ich finde es sieht nicht schlecht
aus aber es schmeckt noch besser absolut
Geist Gericht gibt es bei uns in
Deutschland viel zu selten wir müssen
natürlich auch das Setting betrachten
was wir uns das Restaurant gerade
anbieten und wir sind zur Mittagszeit da
geht darum dass man vielleicht wenn man
in der Umgebung arbeitet vorbeikommt
sich was reinhören und danach irgendwie
wieder zu Arbeit gehen kann und das ist
das perfekte Format einfach so einfaches
Gericht kommt seit zwei Jahren absoluter
win für mich sehr ehrlich also ist nicht
irgendwie so mit Pinzette angerichtet
oder so ich muss aber dazu sagen das
Gericht ist das von den dreien wo ich
wahrscheinlich die Messlatte am
niedrigsten habe weil zum einen habe ich
sehr sehr krasse Rahmen gegessen nicht
zuletzt im Mittel Tokio in Düsseldorf
auf der Bus quasi Rahmen wie in Japan
gibt und Smash Burger mache ich auch
sehr gerne deshalb testen wir das
nächste Mal den Smash Burger aber das
werde ich auch noch mit Freude aufessen
sehr lecker hier haben wir jetzt den
Smash Burger double Smash Burger der
schlägt mit 17,90 € zu Buche ist somit
also das teuerste Gericht und ich muss
auch sagen der muss irgendwas besonderes
machen weil ich finde 17,90 € für ein
Smash Burger ist schon eine Ansage wir
dürfen gerade in die Küche gucken und
bei der Zubereitung wird der Smash
Burger vorher
gelegt ich bin gespannt so kenne ich das
gar nicht er sieht wie gemalt dieser
verschmolzene Käse die Soße obendrauf
spannend fühlt sich auch schon sehr
richtig an eigentlich war fast
eingerichten sind die krassesten Läden
die sich spezialisieren also einladen
der nur Smash Burger macht ein Laden nur
napolitanische Pizza macht deshalb finde
ich den Ansatz hier sehr sehr wild ja
perfektionierungsgrad ist sehr
interessant
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall gut unten raus sehr
saftig aber da fängt es an also der muss
saftig sein aber der muss nicht so
Tropfen versteht ihr was ich meine weil
beim Smash Burger wird das Fleisch ja so
dünn ausgestrichen dass es quasi
komplett durchgebraten wird und nur das
Fett quasi da drin gefangen wird ich
weiß jetzt schon nach dem ersten
bisschen dass ich den hier
wahrscheinlich nicht noch mal bestellen
würde einfach von dem Feeling her weil
ich finde man kann so krank selbst
Beispiele machen aber es ist mein besten
Willen kein schlechter wahres so ganz
guter ich habe einfach in meinem Leben
viel zu viele Burger gegessen das was
ich im Smash Burger Liebe so dieses
ultra karamellisierte Fleisch und diese
Homogenität das ist so ein etwas wird
hat er nicht ganz perfekt getroffen ich
glaube viele würden ihn trotzdem sehr
gerne mögen für mich der stärkste Burger
den ich bisher gelesen habe willst du
mal probieren weil du hast ja auch die
Smash Burger aus dem Büro gegessen und
so also ganz gerne normalen
Bürgermeister
ich habe ganz gut rüber gebracht was ich
meine kein schlechter Burger bisschen
teuer vielleicht für 17,90 eher normaler
Bürger als Bürger und als drittes haben
wir unsere ebi Rahmen wir kriegen für
15,80 € jede Menge essen also wir haben
hier hier einmal das Fried Chicken das
krass aussieht so mit diesem fein
geschnittenen Frühlingszwiebeln bisschen
Sesam an so ein bisschen Klebreis auf
jeden Fall und unsere Rahmen bei der
Rahmen bin ich sehr gespannt weil diese
Brühe das ist auch so ein
perfektionsding ich finde es wie gesagt
echt krass wie breit gefächert die Karte
so ich liebe es ne weil ich finde alle
Sachen lecker die darauf stehen aber ich
habe halt auch alle Sachen die auf dem
schon in sehr sehr gute Ausführungen
gegessen wenn wir uns einmal die Brühe
angucken ich persönlich liebe halt so
nie so eine trüben Miso Brühe das ist so
eine kräftige Brühe vielleicht eine
Rinderbrühe ich probiere mal oh ja jetzt
gerade fällt mir auch dass ich dumm bin
ist eine garnelenbrühe also auf jeden
Fall so ein kräftiger fischiger
Geschmack wir haben auch wirklich
ordentlich Öl auf der Oberfläche also da
ist auf jeden Fall viel Power dahinter
krank also der Fisch Geschmack Schallert
richtig rein muss man mögen aber in
Hamburg ist das auf jeden Fall sehr
gelungen würde ich sagen dann haben wir
noch einen anderen klingt immer ein
heißt das glaube ich also dieses Ei was
im Idealfall innen drin noch flüssig ist
normalerweise kriegt man immer nur ein
halbes die kriegt man Ganzes und es hat
dieses perfekt flüssige Eigelb das ist
schon mal sehr unpoint diese Paprika
Fäden und so ist auch sehr liebe
eingerichtet geil positiv überrascht von
der Rahmen ich dachte wirklich wie kann
das auch noch auf der Karte stehen wie
kann das auch noch funktionieren weil
die ist so kräftig so stark kurzes
Zwischenfazit ich liebe das Restaurant
ich fühle mich hier sehr wohl man kriegt
safe geiles Essen die Speisenauswahl ist
richtig geil und es garantiert ein
Restaurant wo ich wieder hingehen würde
probieren
[Musik]
sehr lecker was auch bemerkenswert ist
jetzt zur Mittagszeit wird quasi das
gesamte Restaurant nur von zwei Jungs in
der Küche versorgt die haben quasi alles
wie so ein Platz alles vorgeschnitten
vorbereitet und geben da richtig Vollgas
und das ist wirklich bemerkenswert also
dass diese verschiedenen Gerichte in so
einer nicen Quali kommen ist geil
Hähnchen Koteletts paniert und frittiert
sondern geil etwas salzigen Soße und die
frische von den Frühlingszwiebeln und
nicht ultra knusprig aber auch nicht
schlimm sehr geil und vor allem finde
ich auch fair also so ein Topf Karaoke
für 4,90 € extra mega gut als kann man
auch für richtig viel falsch machen auch
wenn man denkt das ist sehr Basic ist
Geil Geil gekocht drei Gerichte haben
wir probiert das Restaurant betrachtet
mir gefällt sehr gut also probstzer ja
dann wenn ich wieder kommen würde würde
ich mir am besten wahrscheinlich das
kannst du noch mal bestellen weil das
ist einfach nichts für jeden Tag das
kann man richtig gut knallen finde ich
Burger das hier das hier geil aber
außergewöhnlich
das ging so wie am Schnürchen das Video
habe ich das Gefühl ich hoffe ihr habt
den Einblick genossen wir lassen uns
noch weiter schmecken wir können gerne
hier den Kanal abonnieren hier unten ist
ein für dich vorgeschlagenes Video bis
dahin gerade wir sehen uns macht's gut
ciao